bonjour on vous laisse se présenter
correctement puisque on va être voisin
bah oui quand même alors
d'accord au revoir
vous êtes toujours aussi déplaisant je
ne suis pas des blessants
vous n'êtes pas
chaque mot que vous dites fait vraiment
chaud
[Musique]
non qu'est-ce qu'il fabrique je me gare
en parallèle parallèle à quoi vous
amusez pas de laisser ce rap pisser à
nouveau dans mon aller l'écoute pas il
sait pas qui fait ça c'était forcément
l'un de vous
excuse-moi d'arriver en retard tout le
quartier paraolo en souffrant ça ne
tourne pas rond quand tu es pas là
[Musique]
tu me manques
j'y vais en noir et blanc avant de
rencontrer Sonia veux-tu m'épouser
elle était la couleur
vous prenez les autres pour des critères
et vous croyez de voir tout gérer tout
seul
personne n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
j'aime pas voir un crétin à prendre à
quelqu'un à tenir un volant le centre de
conduite
je vous présente notre ami hop
freiner la voiture est à l'arrêt j'ai
failli rentrer dedans
mon père souriait comme ça lui aussi je
ne sourit pas